y se resuelve la desigualdad para x más
8 menor o igual que 6 y gráfica la
solución entonces tenemos x + 8 es menor
o igual que 6 resolvemos esta
desigualdad para xy la mejor manera de
aislar a la x es simplemente en este
caso del lado izquierdo es simplemente
deshacernos de este 8 y nos deshacemos
de ese 8 simplemente restando lo de
ambos lados de la desigualdad así que
hagamos eso restamos 8 de ambos lados y
eso no va a cambiar el signo de la
desigualdad entonces del lado izquierdo
tenemos tenemos x más 8 menos 8 es igual
a x y del lado derecho tenemos 6 menos 8
es igual a menos 2 x es menor o igual
que menos 2 y ya resolvimos la
desigualdad x es menor o igual que menos
2 ahora vamos a graficar esto en la
recta numérica voy a dibujar aquí una
recta numérica aquí pongo al cero aquí
al 1 aquí al menos 1 - 2 - 3 y queremos
graficar a todos los x que son menor o
igual que menos 2 dado que pueden ser
igual a menos 2
entonces vamos a llenar este espacio y
todos los valores que son menor o igual
que menos 2 están en la solución si no
tuviéramos este igual y solamente
tuviéramos el menor entonces aquí no
tocaría al 2 pero como es menor o igual
que menos 2 entonces vamos a incluir al
2 y todos los valores que son menor que
eso también están incluidos ahora
podemos verificarlo con algunos valores
tomemos por ejemplo al menos 3 el menos
3 debe funcionar entonces menos 3 más 8
es igual a 5 y 5 es menor o igual que 6
así que si funciona si lo intentamos con
el menos 1 no debe funcionar entonces
vamos a verificar eso menos 1 más 8 eso
es igual a 7 y 7 no es menor o igual que
6 entonces estamos en lo correcto